this is my simple message fashion has no
age
can you give me advice to amplify my
message again the number one way in the
world today to amplify a message is to
be on as many social network platforms
as possible and make content that's
contextual to it so for example I know
for a fact that your content would crush
on LinkedIn however I believe everyone
watching and everyone in the room that's
not the natural place they would go but
I know that that's an opportunity
because it acts like Facebook which has
got plenty of reach on organic posts and
there's just a ton of people there yes
they might be in a professional setting
but one of your posts there may find
itself to an editor of a fashion brand
or publication in Asia that would have
never seen you because that executive
isn't actively consuming on Instagram
and Tick Tock take advantage of the free
reach that social networks provide and
maximize that being great at making
content for them